let's go back to Discord and hear from a
few more people first and foremost I
want to go to Adrian from Wyoming what I
I don't know why Wyoming is so
interesting to me I've never been it is
such a small population I would like to
visit Adrian and see what it's all about
you know
hi David pleasure pleasure to speak with
you can you hear me yes I can
perfect
um yeah I live in Laramie um so my
parents actually grew up in New York but
my parents um both teach at the
University of Wyoming
um uh it's the only four-year school in
the state so it's kind of an anomaly
when it comes to like all the other
small rural towns but it's beautiful you
should actually definitely go drive
through the mountains and see it all but
that's not um the focus of my question I
was actually wondering a little bit
about a different part of the world sure
in that
um I know so you uh were born in
Argentina and I was wondering there's an
emerging group Within
um the South American left like leaders
like Petro um
Castillo until he was ousted
um uh amlo I can't remember I don't know
if Castro is part of it
um in in Central America but I was
wondering if you were thinking
um what your thoughts are on this new
rise of what this leaders like Lula and
if it's built to last or if it's
potentially
um susceptible to a more right-wing
takeovers like we just saw in Peru and
what the left in South America would
need to do to ensure that it's got more
staying power as it's a relatively new
phenomenon listen I don't know if it has
staying power I know that on this issue
there's some people in the audience who
like to say oh I'm some right winger and
my family was part of the Argentinian
right wing and that's how we were able
to get out and we were supporters of the
dictatorship in our you know none of
that stuff is true uh all of my family
has been on the left and many are even
further left than I am and uh you know I
have no
um sort of like familial opposition to
left Wingers in Latin America the
concern I've had with some of the Latin
American so-called left-wing leaders of
the last 20 years is that often it's the
exact same sort of Playbook it's the
populist rhetoric and they do some good
things for the poor but they rape and
pillage many of the resources of the
countries in some cases they abscond
with obscene amounts of Cash There's not
always freedom of the press there's not
always freedom of the courts we've seen
in Venezuela and elsewhere so I don't
take any kind of like big picture this
is good or this is bad I'm on the left
right so like as I've said before
between bolsonaro and Lula if those are
my choices I'm picking Lula I also have
concerns about Lula and I outlined them
in the video I did about him and I I
have to say it a thousand times I still
choose him over Bolson
but I don't think Lula is God's gift to
Progressive politics either you know so
I think we just have to wait and see and
evaluate these individually
absolutely I just I I hope that they're
like I hope that um
I'm gonna say I was just in Colombia and
I was speaking with a lot of like my
younger friends there who say they
um they have hope but they're um
and they're but they're a little worried
uh because the The Divide here is
relatively Stark like as in the um in
the US between like younger and older
Generations as to the image of the ideal
Society going forward
um so yeah I was just curious about your
take and I appreciate the call
thank you very much for your time all
right thank you Adrian from Wyoming
great to hear from you very much
appreciate it imagine for a second that
you try logging into your email account
only to find that your password was
changed an hour ago and then you get
notifications of activity from your bank
and then your credit cards that is what
identity theft is like and it's a
horrible feeling and we dealt with it at
the show not that long ago but now I
have an app called Aura which gives me
much more peace of mind our sponsor Aura
is the all-in-one solution for keeping
your online account safe because Aura
will scan the dark web for your personal
info passwords social security number
and you get fast alerts when they find
something you also get fast alerts about
credit inquiries Aura protects all of
your devices from malware or even
requests the removal of your info from
data broker sites and Aura helps you
manage what your kids can do on their
devices you can restrict certain apps
set screen time limits set Focus times
when you need them off of devices go to
aura.com Pacman to try it free for seven
days your login credentials might
already be floating around out there and
Aura will tell you instantly for free
the link is down below